mann oder frau nord oder süd west oder
ost linker flügel oder rechter flügel
bei der besetzung der ministerien ging
es so stark wie noch nie immer häufiger
um quoten gerade bei den grünen und der
spd hat man bei den debatten gemerkt bei
der besetzung der spitze des
ministeriums da war ausschlaggebend ist
die person jetzt aus der in
anführungszeichen richtigen region ist
die person ein mann oder eine frau und
bei den grünen kam dann noch hinzu die
debatte linker oder rechter flügel und
wenn dann zum beispiel cem özdemir über
dem wir eben gesprochen haben ausgewählt
wurde als minister dann bedeutet das
dass eine dame vom real hat flügel
weichen musste kathrin göring-eckardt
und dann kam eine vom linken flügel die
dann aber wiederum auch aus einer
gewissen region sein musste und deswegen
sage ich ganz klar so kann es nicht
weitergehen in zukunft muss wieder
stärker in der politik auf leistung und
kompetenz geachtet werden und nicht auf
die quote wir brauchen wir brauchen das
eine stärkung des leistungsprinzips und
wir brauchen am ende nicht immer mehr
faktoren für die menschen auch häufig
nichts können bei der auswahl unserer
politischen spitzenämter er plötzlich
kann ihn eigentlich nur recht geben aber
mich wundert so sehr dass sie das thema
heute mitgebracht haben als
unionsvertreter weil ich habe mich heute
sehr aufgeregt und zwar mit blick auf
die bundespräsidentin und zwar sagt die
union ja jetzt ja wir schicken eine frau
ins rennen weil wir hatten die erste
kanzlerin die hat mir erst
verteidigungsministerin wir kriegen
jetzt auch die alt-bundespräsidenten wo
ich dachte okay es geht also es nur
darum dass die union die erste frau
setzt also gerade die union macht doch
gerade schlagzeilen es sieht jetzt eine
frau ins rennen schicken wollen fürs
bundespräsidentenamt weil sie überall
immer die erste frau gesetzt haben ich
bin ja eine frau ich kann sagen ich mag
das nicht dass immer also was jetzt auch
die union macht ich finde lass uns über
die leistung von herr steinmeier
sprechen ist sehr gut genug zum
weitermachen aber die union soll jetzt
nicht nur eine frau ins rennen schicken
um die erste frau besetzt zu haben das
brauchen wir nicht finde ich wir frauen
starb jetzt auch alleine worauf ja
einige kollegen hingewiesen haben war
dass wir die erste kanzlerin gestellt
haben tatsächlich
auch die
präsidentin verteidigungsministerin war
ja manche gerade von spd und grünen
immer so suggerieren naja die cdu hätte
ein frauenproblem sieht man wie gesagt
wir wollen jetzt auch die erste bundes
genau ja ich persönlich habe ja auch
meine meinung eben ziemlich deutlich zum
ausdruck gebracht ich glaube bei der
besetzung von politischen spitzenämtern
darf ist nicht ausschlaggebend sein ist
jetzt die person mann oder eine frau
sondern muss auf die kompetenzen ich
habe auch überhaupt kein problem damit
wenn zum beispiel nehmen wir mal an wir
hätten vier ämter zu vergeben und das
sind vier frauen weil die frauen einfach
gut sind und die qualifiziertesten wären
also ich bin auch überhaupt nicht dafür
dass wir eine männerquote bräuchten aber
wir müssen eben stärker wieder auf
kompetenz schauen und sonst ist übrigens
auch unfair ist genauso wie der fdp ist
gemacht ich habe das jetzt auch nicht
fdp die haben drei ausschussvorsitzende
zu vergeben drei frauen wir haben vier
minister wir haben als justizministern
volljuristen mit prädikat der das schon
im rechtsausschuss gemacht hat der sich
genau den bereichen auskennt mit dem
verkehrsamt digital minister einen der
das in rheinland pfalz schon so gemacht
hat und der wissenschaftsministerin eine
wissenschaftsmanagerin die das genauso
ich habe jetzt auf einmal recht geben
ich wir haben ja heute werden wir heute
auch
wir können auch eine in der sache in der
sache glaube ich hat die fdp tatsächlich
eine richtige vorgehensweise ghadir
gehabt die hat geguckt welche person ist
geeignet für das ministerium nicht
lieber schwan hat jetzt auch schon ein
zwei böcke geschossen
in der letzten woche aber zumindest hat
man gesagt da stimmt die kompetenz und
da gibt es eine begründung auch abseits
der geschlechter fragen und das ist
glaube ich auch für die bürger in
unserem land entscheiden die wollen ja
jetzt regiert werden von menschen die es
drauf haben und denen es die meiste ist
dann auch egal ist dass jetzt aber
nicht dass in der union eigentlich im
letzten 16 jahren wenn man sich das
kabinett angeschaut hat genauso auch
verfahren wurde nach ost west nord süd
der proporz und dann immer die frage wie
weit ist baden württemberg beteiligt und
wie weit ist nordrhein westfalen
beteiligt zu viel was ist mit dem osten
eigentlich um der community sie
ordnungen und dann dürfen die frau nicht
vergessen und am liebsten noch jemand
auch mit migrationshintergrund also das
was sie sagen sie sind mitglied der mit
cdu frau hat gesagt der cdu
hoffnungsträger aber genau das ist doch
eigentlich in letzten 16 jahren bei der
union genauso auch hätte wir sind wir
sind keine quoten partei das ist klar
und ab jeder dritte platz auf einer
liste gesetzt werden der soll vorschrift
dass er auch noch mal was anderes und
natürlich haben wir allen bewusst sein
wir werden am 12 plätze zu vergeben und
das während zwölf männer dann würde
jeder sein das geht heutzutage nicht
immer so ein grund bewusstsein ich
glaube ich überall vorhanden aber was
warum es mir jetzt ja eben gegen war
dass wir nicht so ein up c fans machen
also wo ist ja jetzt eine aus dem neuen
ein aus dem süden daneben noch man
frauen es kommt immer mehr faktoren
hinzu und das ganze karussell dreht sich
immer weiter und in der tat haben sie
einen punkt glaube ich gemacht immer
schäfer dass auch bei uns in den
vergangenen jahren zu stark auf die
himmelsrichtung manchmal geschaut wurde
auch zu stark vielleicht aufs geschlecht
und das hat natürlich manchmal auch zu
unzufriedenheit bei der wählerschaft
geführt das ist wenn wir gründlich
analysieren über das wahlergebnis
nun müssen wir auch sagen wir müssen als
cdu in zukunft weniger proporz an den
tag legen und eben auch stärker auf die
qualifikation und auf die kompetenz
schauen nur dass herr ausschlaggebend
also das ist ja interessant also auf der
einen seite was ich glaube sie haben sie
eine ratio von 80 20 80 prozent männer
und 20 prozent frauen im deutschen
bundestag wenn sie sagen das soll die
kompetenz regieren dann muss man sieht
ist das offenbar ihre meinung dass 80
prozent männer die bessere kompetent
zu viel zu reden und ich rede jetzt
zuschaut wenn 80 prozent sind dann
können diese 80 prozent nicht alle
schlauer sein als diese zum zweiten
haben wir eine frau zum beispiel silvia
der cdu-vize frau die auf der anderen
seite gesagt hat es vor kurzem ich wäre
ja gerne cdu-vorsitzende ich werde es
nicht weil die vereinbarkeit von familie
und beruf in unserer partei überhaupt
nicht gegeben ist ich kann nicht mit
drei kindern hier sonntags nachmittags
ab und die kinder alleine lassen weil
das geht einfach nicht auch nicht in
unserer partei also da gibt es doch die
defizite und solange sie das nicht
ändern wird auch niemand in der partei
hoch kommt dann sage ich hut ab für all
denjenigen die sagen quote gilt weil in
diesen zuständen wird es nie eine frau
schaffen in ihren in ihrem land aber
anja daraus erhalten und den haushalt
diejenigen die irgendwelche
betreuungssystem haben die mir genug
geld und mittel haben von zu hause da
fällt mir zum beispiel jemand ein oder
in höchsten ämtern in europa oder auf
der anderen seite eben ja allein stehen
weil sie lange an da geben sie mir eine
steilvorlage weil er so wie gehts ja mir
geht es ja nicht darum mit dass ich an
den strukturen nichts ändern soll ich
habe zum beispiel als ich
landesvorsitzender wurde bei mir in
hamburg gesagt wir müssen die strukturen
ändern damit zum beispiel ist kein
problem mehr ist die familie und das
politische engagement zu vereinbaren
deswegen haben wir zum beispiel sehr
sehr viel digitale formate wir haben
sogar kinderbetreuung etabliert damit
eben eine frau nicht sagen muss ich muss
mich jetzt entscheiden deswegen die
strukturen ändern dass alle mitmachen
können und niemand aufgrund von den
kindern abgehalten wird halte ich für
ganz wichtig nur eine quote sorgt dafür
dass im prinzip gleiche ergebnisse
vorher geschaffen werden und dass am
ende auch alles gleich gemacht wird also
wir müssen wir unterscheiden im prinzip
zwischen gleichberechtigung und zweimal
gleichen rahmenbedingungen für alle und
gleichmacherei bzw gleichstellung oder
quoten und die cdu als bürgerliche
partei sollte lieferquoten sein sondern
eben dafür dass alle möglichst gleiche
chancen haben deswegen nehme ich den
punkt auf aber er ist eher ein argument
warum man auch nicht quoten einen punkt
machen bevor jetzt wieder auf twitter
debattiert wird wie vier männer
überhaupt über quoten und frauen
debattieren können als nicht so sehr
stört ich weiß ja gar nicht ob ich für
dagegen die frauenquote bin als einzige
thema zu dem ich keine meinung mir
bislang gebildet haben eine absolute
aber was ich so schlimm finde es sollte
nicht mehr auf das mindset ankommen zum
beispiel mein berufliches vorbild ist
ein mann das ist mein vater der für mich
ein feministisches und ich frage mich
halt manchmal sollte man nicht mehr
darauf achten wie derjenigen von der
einstellung ist es gibt ja auch frauen
die andere frauen nicht fördern also
sollte man sich lieber darauf achten
weil ich finde immer das geschlecht
warum hat das geschlecht plötzlich bei
uns in der gesellschaft so einen
riesigen stellenwert wider wie beim
gendern wir überall sagen der mann frau
mann frau es wäre jetzt so wichtig viele
menschen die zb transsexuellen die
wollen das gar nicht das geschlecht eine
rolle spielt
sehen wir die beste die beste die beste
erklärung sehen wir in ihren bann die
zustände sollen geändert werden sie muss
man anerkennen positiv setzen dinge in
bewegung bis dass frauen eben sich
besser entfalten können sich besser
einbringen können bis das aber der fall
ist sind jahre jahrzehnte vielleicht
sogar überhaupt nicht weil mir haben wir
zum beispiel in den gremien über 40
prozent wenn wir mal in die wirtschaft
vielleicht einmal die wirtschaft schauen
beispielsweise in die wirtschaft in die
metallindustrie zum beispiel gibt es ja
werbering mittelständische unternehmen
gibt größere metallindustrie unternehmen
die ja dann auch idealerweise jeden
dritten posten im vorstand mit einer
frau besetzen sollen wenn man jetzt
jeden dritten posten mit einer frau
besetzt würde man sagen ein drittel der
belegschaft müssten eigentlich auch
frauen seien einfach nur rein um zu
sagen okay ich gerade meine quote ja ein
drittel frauen jetzt ist das aber gar
nicht so in der metallindustrie gibt es
relativ stabil wenn man über die
vergangenen ein zwei drei jahrzehnte
schaut ein anteil männer zu frauen von
75 zu 25 prozent und
metallindustrie zum welt ist ob das
jetzt vergleiche aber oder wie in der
zone sagen will ist und man hört dass
auch immer wieder von arbeitgebern die
sagen wir tun wir machen wir bewerben
uns um ganz ganz viele weibliche
auszubildende
aber irgendwie haben die nicht zu den
drang aus welchen gründen auch immer die
metallindustrie das wissen wir eine
branche in der man extrem gut verdienen
kann bremen und jetzt ist doch die
verlage jetzt habe ich eine quote um es
mal ganz überspitzt zu formulieren die
sagt zwei zu eins also zwei männer und
eine frau auf drei positionen habe aber
nur in der belegschaft einschnitte von 3
zu 1 und dann wird's natürlich irgendwie
cool aber das passt nur wenn die bilder
denn die führung sich aus der
belegschaft bildet da haben wir das
problem in der metallindustrie dass ich
oft an dem oben betriebswirte volkswirte
juristen und so weiter braucht und unten
brauche ich dem schlosser den dreher und
so weiter bei der demokratie allerdings
da gebe ich recht da ist das anders
sehen ja ein phänomen ganz kurz wenn das
mal sagen dafür sehen ja wie groß der
bedarf an frauen ist die ja natürlich
jüngste untersuchung bei den
vorstandsmitgliedern im dax mdax sdax
frauen verdienen im schnitt jetzt haltet
euch alle fest
500.000 euro mehr fast ein drittel mehr
als die männlichen kollegen der logen
vorstellen richtig natürlich weiß wie
weit ein knappes gut
das gut ist weil es eine quote wie viele
diese quote erfüllen wollen was gleich
hat ist egal was da jetzt was aber etwas
anderes heißt alle frauen die jetzt zu
schauen entweder weil sich selber noch
können weil sie in der ausbildung noch
richtig entschieden haben macht das
zweitens alle die kinder haben den
kindern auch sagen pass auf du kannst
auch das da ist doch noch der durchbruch
den wir noch nicht haben nämlich rollen
definition deswegen lass macht junge las
er acht mädchen ja und da sage ich für
die politik dann zum schluss alle die
jetzt zuschauen geht in der partei ist
kann auch die cdu sein das kann die fdp
die meiste war ist könnte sogar grünen
oder spd aber wir haben zu wenig frauen
und dann in den parteien auf den pater
sei ich will keine parteitage mehr
abends um 19 uhr haben wenn ich eine
familie habe für macht das andere das so
funktioniert am ende bis dahin kann
partei versuchen zu fördern aber mir
nicht